what is one word you would use to
describe season 14
traumatizing
hello divas how are you
hello hello how are you i heard y'all
had to get into drag pretty early this
morning so thank you you look fabulous i
want to start with talking about the
game-changing twists we're going to get
this season 14 rupaul candy bars but
only one bar could save your padded ass
what was your reaction when you learned
what roo had in store for you this year
when it was announced we're like oh this
changes everything
like
everybody goes into drag queens with a
certain amount of strategy and a certain
amount of like idea of like this is how
this is going to play out
and this twist through a wrench in like
kind of everything that we had planned
where does it rank in drag race history
are we talking about like teams
competing together on all stars one or
like silky nutmeg ganache doing 27 lip
syncs straight hopefully you weren't
referring to me as silky
are all iconic moments but they do not
stand a chance for season 14's twist let
me just say that it is finger looking
good
and you guys are up to beg okay did you
not see my face of the trailer
i couldn't handle i needed someone to
check my palms i couldn't it's it's the
law it's a lot yeah hurry have you
recovered from the twist
oh honey i'm still recovering i'm all
twisted around to be honest it's it's a
like oh my gosh it's like when you said
like comparing the two it's like all
that and more plus some mixed in a
blender thrown backwards and then like
just given to everyone for entertainment
yeah huh oh yeah i think we're still
shocked at the stuff that took place um
especially me you know i'll be having a
little nightmare sometimes um
like in panic mode waking up in the
middle of the night thinking about it
but it was all good stuff it's all great
it's definitely gonna be very gaggy in
my opinion june cornbread told me she
still has ptsd from this twist is that
an accurate assessment yes so i don't
like i already didn't eat chocolate but
if i see a chocolate bar like i just you
know looked here that's why we tune into
drag race you know that's why i'm
excited for this season also because the
star power in season 14 i mean the guest
judges are insane uh who are you guys
most star struck by i think
ah jlo definitely
jlo even jayla's looking at you like
damn oh my god my fellow leo sister j.lo
i mean when we figured we like found out
that she was on i was like no way like
honey they got the budget this season
so i was literally in my robe
getting ready and then like lizzle just
uh turned around and i literally lost my
[ __ ] like
i it was yeah it wasn't for me
oh my god daiya who is it for you
well without giving too much away um our
alicia keys hands down like 100
especially growing up she's just kind of
that icon that everybody knew and loved
and the fact that we got to be face to
face with her i won't tell you exactly
how we got face to face with her the
first time
but we were all grouped and gagged it's
like a favorite pokemon character which
one alicia keys yeah hand yeah hands
down because i've literally been
listening to her music since i was a
little kid not too much like she she
draws pearls of wisdom a lot like she
has a weird word
yeah she
oh looks like she's not wearing any
makeup i was like is she wearing
she's she's just period they say they're
saying right and we got all of this was
there a comment or a critique from one
of these guest judges that kind of stuck
with you or resonated yeah actually uh
what
i'm not gonna say who okay but one of
the guest judges actually um
shed a tear while she was critiquing me
because i think she kind of saw right
through me and saw who i was and related
to me in a in a very quick second so
that was really like
holy [ __ ] like we're doing the damn
thing this season
[Music]